The New York Times has put together a
composite ranking
up where americans are healthy and
wealthy
or where they're struggling and
analytical a graph okay so the time came
to this conclusion by looking at six
data points for each county in the
United States may include
an education median household income
unemployment rate disability raid
life expectancy and obesity alright so
by where you doing worse the more read
her the more are injured gets
I are the places you doing worse so I
the South
not new in that well the tiny orange dot
by New York City at a movie theater over
there is the Bronx are not doing that
well in the Bronx I
Northern California I was surprised not
doing as well as I would have thought
now we're in So Cal be here and we're
doing okay
I but again the saudis by brother is the
Midwest seems to be okay
a Florida I thought was kinda
interesting because the beaches
all are in good shape but if you're in
the middle of our to you're not new in
too well is there anything the middle of
our Derby maybe the beach is a hundred
years exactly Miami by the time we
finish the show could be
plan example your day will be a coral
reef the time even if the shoe yeah
exactly
um show to rate their the it's the
highest concentration of doing worse
right in the heart of the voting against
their own interests belt okay a reason
alabama won for Romney and you're
looking at it right now
yeah so what's going on in that in that
are injured area
Luis can you gain color-blind to
actually can see this matter
I just trust me I
it's not doing too well in South days no
I thought that pretty really interesting
I wasn't sure that they include obesity
um in there and because unemployment the
city and everyone else was in there
um but it seems very subjective I'm
always think about these things in terms
of like
my life Thomas office of Mah person
social thinking alike in Los Angeles
being a piece lot harder than I feel
like it is
in in some others I'm blue place in the
midwest right
I'm just saying knows my personal
opinion yeah I'm with you think there's
a connection
between happiness and gay marriage
because apparently by that
map it looks like there's some
connection the places where gays are
okay
there's something ways I okay I mean
there's lots of states where
where marriage equality has come about
because I've activism by
a morally awakened populace and other
states where judges just said no and
whether you like it or not so I don't
they don't think it's me those crazy
activist judges Williams
radically doing things that are you help
people you're an activist judge if you
help corporations aristocrats I
factory but i i do think that that on in
many cases you know that you know in a
more progressive place where you have
if you get the people abroad about
marriage equality the same people %uh
probably what about a higher wage
less income inequality and therefore
more happiness its wide Denmark is much
happier than we are
and why the American dream really should
be called the Scandinavian dream
because they enjoy a much higher
standard of living less income
inequality
and day you know no one goes bankrupt
ever
trying to pay for health care but are
they not is Priya's this and that
they're more free than us you know I'm
just yeah think
I some so what made this is rather have
a broader than because there was one
that I thought was particularly
interesting there
wyoming they're pretty happy in wyoming
there's a
17 a yeah and they're so is that we're
doing really well so Wyoming hopefully
if you
if you need to look at a map by looking
at this to figure out why I mother in
the middle up I love to see when North
Dakota looks like in five years because
the fracking economy is gonna change the
entire economic make up the whole state
and you can go to a place that was a one
stop sign town a year ago and make six
figures now driving a truck up there
and fracking will change the entire
economy of north dakota
wreck so you make a lot of money through
fracking but your water might be
exploding
I guess that could be a press over if
your water explodes in your face even if
you're in a big bet the house
but I wouldn't be too happy me doing
worse dollar had a fire going here
director so it might suddenly get better
and then when the exploding water comes
then it'll get where we know something
the factors tutor to back into the same
is it was a very it is very interesting
and just I don't get a complete picture
the I means so Wyoming that's why I
think Wyoming interesting one because
there are so few people there
yet they seem Paso is that partly it
there
Highlanders chased drop in the rate I
get dizzy so that's why happiness has
gone up there that have this gene is
this end
up